nous avons gardé le cap sur ce qui était
vraiment importante
le nouvel accord devait préserver les
emplois favoriser la croissance
élargir que la classe moyenne et
soutenir les gens qui travaillent fort
pour concert article nous avons réussi à
faire tout cela
richard ouellette et professeur à
l'université laval spécialiste du libre
échange du commerce international il est
notre analyste ce soir bonsoir richard
wallet
bonsoir est-ce qu'on signe un nouvel
accord aujourd'hui le même accord une
annexe
d'après ce que je comprends on signe
protocole qui apporte des modifications
à l'accord signé l'an dernier donc la
nouvelle signature ne qu'on semble avoir
vu cet après midi ne porte que sur un
protocole qui apporte des modifications
et qui fait en sorte donc classé home
l'accord le nouvel accord qui va
remplacer remplacer l'alena pourra aller
de l'avant prochaine étape donc la
ratification
oui prochaine étape la ratification un
vote devrait être pris à la chambre des
représentants aux états unis avant noël
pour une ratification par la suite tôt
dans l'année 20 20 est du côté canadien
semble que ce soit la fin janvier qu'on
pourra procéder à des votes qu'il faut
pour ensuite avoir la sanction royale et
le texte de la cia hommes et cette
partie là n'a pas été changée prévoit
que trois mois après la notification du
troisième état à avoir satisfait sa
constitution trois mois après donc il y
est entré en vigueur de ce nouvel accord
donc si le canada ratifie fin janvier
fin février et fin mars fin avril-début
mai peut-être ce sera donc vraiment en
vigueur à ce vol oui à maintenant après
le théâtre fait qu'il ya des
rebondissements à tout moment et si on
avait à faire une prédiction aujourd'hui
ce serait celle-là on a eu quelques
semaines quand même depuis quelques
années quelques points points majeurs ce
sont les normes du travail plus strictes
pour le mexique aujourd'hui oui alors
les américains sont très inquiets du
fait que le mexique ne rehausserait pas
ces normes environnementales et ses
normes en matière de travail
ce que le mexique s'est engagé à faire
et donc les états unis ont voulu une
capacité de vérification de ce
rehaussement des normes ce qui semble
avoir obtenu par un mécanisme qui
permettrait de faire un certain nombre
d'inspections et au besoin de prendre
des sanctions commerciales contre le
mexique
s'il ne remplit pas ses promesses donc
c'est une avancée importante dans la
protection des travailleurs c'est
important de faire ça c'est important de
faire ça je ne suis pas sûr que les
américains les faits avec le souci de
rehausser les normes sociales pour les
travailleurs mexicains ils ont surtout
fait avec l'intention de d'équilibrer
les marchés du travail et américains et
mexicains et donc de se donner de
meilleures perspectives pour rapatrier
des emplois aux etats-unis ce qui est
une donnée très cher au coeur de
l'administration seront donc bloqués en
quelque sorte la délocalisation vers le
mexique parce que les salaires étaient
plus faibles
exactement le secteur de l'acier et pas
l'aluminium et le secteur de l'acier a
gagné une plus forte protection pour ses
usines et ses travailleurs expliqué nous
oui alors on resserre les règles
d'origine pour ce qui est de l'acier il
faut voir une chose par contre c'est que
ce resserrement la des règles d'origine
ne s'opèrent rock sur sept a donc
quelque chose de très lent et ce
resserrement l'a fait qu' on va
augmenter la proportion d'acier
nord-américain dans la fabrication d
automobiles maintenant dans le secteur
de l'aluminium
il n'y a pas ce même âge où je pense
qu'il faut être assez clair il n'y a pas
de sacrifice qui fait à l'égard de
l'aluminium dans la nouvelle mouture on
n'a pas concédé quelque chose c'est
qu'en fait il y à un gain qui est fait
dans le secteur de l'acier qui n'est pas
tout à fait là dans le secteur de
l'aluminium donc
à vos repas ne fait pas une concession
mais c'est pas un gain non plus c'est
ainsi c'est un gain qui s'est fait dans
le secteur de l'acier s'est pas fait
dans le secteur de l'aluminium dans un
marché dont on va parler dans un instant
avec jean simard là dans un marché qui
est assez ébranlé par des mouvements là
avec la chine et le mexique on va parler
dans un instant ça va ce nouvel accord
confirme et de nouvelles brèches dans la
gestion de l'offre
en fait je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure ce sont de nouvelles brèches dans
la gestion dans la foi aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de nouvelles de rush mais
quand on va entrer en vigueur
quand l'accord entre en vigueur on va
mettre en vigueur les nouvelles brèches
dans la gestion de l'offre
oui alors voilà alors là c'est comme lui
même dans sa version de l'an dernier
prévoyait déjà effectivement vous avez
raison de le dire que cette hauteur de 3
59 % du marché des produits laitiers
qu'il y aura nouvelles entrées de
produits américains sur notre marché
effectivement et ses concessions là se
font aussi dans certains petits des
autres dans une bien moindre mesure dans
d'autres secteurs aussi qu'ils sont sous
gestion de l'offre au matin dont les
yeux notamment voit la protection des
brevets des sociétés pharmaceutiques ont
dit que les hausses de prix de
médicaments seront évités oui c'est ça
alors là c'est comme l'an dernier
prévoyait que l'on augmentait à 10 ans
la période de protection des données
pour les médicaments biopharmaceutiques
alors en clair ça veut dire quoi
il ya il ya la question de la mise en
marché d'un produit pharmaceutique mais
il ya aussi la question de la protection
des données c'est la période pendant
laquelle la protection des données
les concurrents peuvent pas aller voir
comment vous avez élaboré votre
médicament et peuvent pas préparé la
copie qu'ils vont mettre en marché comme
médicaments génériques pour la suite
au canada nous avons une période dans
notre loi qui est d'une durée de huit
ans au mexique ils ont une durée de cinq
ans et aux etats-unis longue durée de
douze dans la saison mais l'an dernier
on avait convenu d'une durée de 10 ans
maintenant les démocrates qui ont mis
leur grain de sel dans les négociations
là dans les dernières semaines
eux ont pour objectif plutôt d'améliorer
l'accessibilité aux médicaments dont
qu'ils aiment bien que le médicament
générique arrive plus vite sur le marché
alors ils ont enlevé la clause des
fameuses
fameuse dix ans de protection des
données dans l'accord ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle pour pour le québec par
exemple pour son assurance médicaments
parce que là c'est une baisse de coûts
importantes pour nos régimes publics
intéressant ça très intéressant
un mot en terminant sur l'om c'est le
système de règlement des différends dans
l'alena le nouvel an lunaire sera plus
solide
d'une part et d'autre part le système de
règlement des différends à l'om c'est
aujourd'hui le tribunal d'appel sur le
règlement des différends va devenir
inopérant
dès demain vous dites nous pourquoi oui
alors il y à deux mandats de juge à
l'organe d'appel de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce qui viennent à
terme aujourd'hui
alors le juge américain fameuse grille m
et le président de l'organe d'appel
un indien voient leur mandat se termine
et là aujourd'hui au moment où on se
parle et à partir de demain il n'y aura
qu'une juge qui aura un mandat
ironiquement la juge chinoise oui et cet
état de fait est dû au refus des
américains depuis trois ans maintenant
et même plus de refuser de
de nommer deux nouveaux juges ou de
renouveler des mandats de juge à
l'organe d'appel de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
parce qu'il n'aime pas l'état des
décisions prises par l'organe d'appel
ont servi à milwaukee
oui et là maintenant il n'y a plus de
possibilité d'appel le canada est aux
avant postes dans ce débat là il a
d'ailleurs signé une entente avec
l'union européenne et s'est entendu pour
que tous les cas qui seraient
potentiellement aller en appel
ils iront désormais en arbitrage et on a
un accord formel de gouvernement à
gouvernement avec l'union européenne
pour régler ces enjeux là et il faudra
régler cette question là rapidement
surtout pour un pays comme le canada
merci beaucoup richard wallet ça m'a
fait plaisir merci bien au revoir